cardi b celebrated her 29th birthday
with dinner dancing and diamonds oh yes
honey the grammy winner turns another
year older on monday
but on sunday both cardi and her husband
offset got the party started and
documented the celebration on instagram
the migos rapper shared this clip of
cardi rocking her b-day present a
massive diamond necklace in the shape of
a playboy bunny the wap singer rocked
the bling along with stacks and stacks
of other diamond accessories to her
b-day dinner there's some big big things
on the way big bangs many of cardi's
friends were in attendance at the bash
where the mom of two let loose dancing
singing and drinking wine
and offset he was having the time of his
life too
the birthday girl opened presents which
included this fur coat with her name
embroidered on the inside
[Music]
of course this all comes after cardian
offset welcomed their second son into
the world a son last month the two
announced his arrival on instagram
writing in part quote we are so
overjoyed to finally meet our son he has
already loved so much and cardi who also
shares a three-year-old daughter culture
with her man has been keeping it real
with her fans after they praised her
body after baby number two people been
giving me amazing compliments on my body
everybody's just like carter you so
snatched what do you do you did light
bulb you had a tummy tuck you cannot do
surgery
after you give birth anyways yes that
looks nice especially when i take these
paparazzi pictures and i'm like this i
really like this guys i you know i like
to be real with you guys